the attack in the ukrainian base will
likely not slow the flow of foreign
military equipment being sent by the u.s
and others the pentagon has repeatedly
said it has several routes in and
officials insist aid continues to make
its way in daily meanwhile the ukrainian
foreign minister went on american
television to ask for more what we are
asking is very simple thing we say army
ukraine and we will do the rest
give us all the weapons necessary and we
will fight for our own land and for our
people
he was specifically asking for fighter
jets which the u.s has ruled out for now
senior defense officials tell us that
right now part of the problem is that
russia has the ability to shoot down
fighter jets pretty much over all of
ukraine's airspace so they are looking
at providing ukraine more sophisticated
missile systems than they have thus far
in hopes of keeping the airspace
contested
another big concern for u.s officials
fear that russia could use chemical
weapons but the pentagon spokesman made
an important point on sunday it is of
the russian playbook that that which
they accuse you of they're planning to
do now again we haven't seen anything
indeed it indicates some sort of
imminent chemo chemical biological
attack right now but we're watching this
very very closely on monday the national
security advisor jake sullivan will be
meeting china's top diplomat in rome he
gave a preview of what he'll have to say
we have made it clear to not just
beijing but every country in the world
that if
they think that they can basically bail
russia out
they can give russia a work around to
the sanctions that we've imposed
they should have another thing coming
because we will ensure that neither
china nor anyone else can compensate
russia for these losses a continued push
to isolate russia hurt its economy and
armed ukraine in hopes it is eventually
enough to change russian president
vladimir putin's plans and possibly put
an end to the daily destruction in
ukraine
patty kalhane al jazeera washington